♪ ♪
>> Bret: RUSSIA IS ONCE AGAIN
TONIGHT BEING ACCUSED OF
INTERFERING IN AMERICAN DOMESTIC
AFFAIRS.
THIS TIME IT'S THE NATIONAL
CONVERSATION OVER GUN CONTROL.
SPARKED BY LAST WEEK'S SCHOOL
SHOOTING IN FLORIDA.
FOX NEWS MEDIA ANALYST AND HOST
OF FOX'S "MEDIA BUZZ"
HOWARD KURTZ TELLS US HOW THE
RUSSIANS ARE TRYING TO TURN THE
TRAGEDY TO THEIR ADVANTAGE.
>> AN HOUR AFTER THE FLORIDA
SCHOOL SHOOTING, TWITTER ERUPTED
WITH HASHTAGS AS
#GunControlNow.
WE NOW KNOW HUNDREDS OF SUCH
POSTS CAME FROM TWITTER ACCOUNT
SUSPECTED OF HAVING LINKS TO
RUSSIA.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTS THE
RUSSIAN SOCIAL MEDIA BLITZ IS
PART OF A FAR-REACHING
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN THAT
INCLUDES CONSPIRACY VIDEOS ON
YOUTUBE, PHONY INTEREST GROUPS
ON FACEBOOK, AND SO-CALLED BOTS
THAT CAN DRIVE A TWITTER
DISCUSSION AND PUSH IT INTO THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
ANALYSTS SAY A DIVISIVE SUBJECT
LIKE GUN CONTROL IS FERTILE
GROUND FOR THESE COVERT RUSSIAN
OPERATIVES WHOSE GOAL IS TO FUEL
CONFLICT AND FRUSTRATION IN
AMERICA.
>> THEY ARE TRYING TO FOMENT
DISSENSION AND ANGER.
THEY'RE REALLY TRYING TO GET
AMERICANS TO POINT FINGERS AT
ONE ANOTHER, TO DRIVE WEDGES,
AND DOUBLE DOWN ON FEATURES THAT
EXIST IN OUR SOCIETY.
>> SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER HIGHLIGHTED THE PROBLEM
LAST WEEK WITH INDICTMENTS
AGAINST 13 RUSSIANS FOR CYBER
HACKING AND TRYING TO DISRUPT
THE PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
THESE RUSSIANS ARE ALLEGED TO
HAVE COVERTLY ORGANIZE POLITICAL
RALLIES IN THE U.S.
AFTER THE ELECTION, MUELLER
CHARGES THEY COURTED ONE NEAR
GROWLY "TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP" AND
ANOTHER CALL, "TRUMP IS NOT MY
PRESIDENT."
PROTESTING NFL PLAYERS, THE
RUSSIANS TOOK THEIR CUE FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S CRITICISM BY PUSHING
SUCH HASHTAGS AS #BoycottNFL
AND #StandForOurAnthem."
.
THEY MOVED ONTO THE HASHTAG
#FalseFlag PUSHING AND
OUTLANDISH CONSPIRACY THEORY
STUDENTS HAD REHEARSED THEIR
ACTIONS IN ADVANCE AND THE
TRAGEDY NEVER HAPPENED.
A YEAR OF HEAVY MEDIA COVERAGE
FOSTER THE IMPRESSION RUSSIAN
HACKERS WERE MAINLY INTERESTED
IN PUTTING DONALD TRUMP IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
IT IS NOW CLEAR RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA AND DISINFORMATION
ARE A CONSTANT FACT OF LIFE,